I care for you I love you I want to be
at the end of this engage we're not
I can't
I don't care about to leave now we saw
Cassie leave and you tell Cassie that
you won't stop fighting for her so what
do you do you know I mean there's two
other relationships so you know I'm
obviously have to make the decisions
moving forward you know where where do I
go now what's going to happen next and
you'll get those answers how hard was it
to hear that from her you told her you
loved her yeah I mean that's that was I
think what the toughest part was is I
fall back into you know what I talked
about with Becca and you know being in a
relationship in which the feelings that
were reciprocated at the same level and
not being in the same page was one of
the things that I was fearful and so
that was very hard to hear it was why
fight for someone who walks out on you I
think making that statement is you know
something that I would make in any
relationship that I'm in I mean you have
to choose to love somebody and you have
to choose to fight for anybody that
you're in a relationship with I think
that's what love is and that's what
being in a relationship is all about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]